I think that it's a moment of
vulnerability losses creativity because
if you lose out on something you're
gonna have to still figure out that
problem heartbreak or can't find
something you cherish or loved or
physically losing something loss to me
is something so great that it ends up
changing you as a person whether it's
for good or for bad to me loss means
gaining perspective loss for me is a
time where you're allowed to feel
horrible you're allowed to feel really
messed up but ultimately you get to come
out of it kind of inner rebirth I think
of loss I think of death I think of what
that means that how you deal with time
the time that you have left here
[Music]
I was dating a white guy a couple years
ago and I happened to be in Italy at the
time his parents found out I was black
and we're not very happy with that it
kind of led to the dissolution of the
relationship it's funny because I had
just bought the figurine and as I was
coming back to the States the figurine
literally split rightward the two parts
meet so it's like the black piece is not
sewn piece and the white piece is now
its own piece I think the biggest loss
that I had There was that like I kind of
lost myself in that relationship I feel
like that's an L that I've slowly been
trying to come to terms with is that
like it's never okay to stomach racist
parents for a relationship when I was in
high school my seven-year-old little
sister got diagnosed with leukemia
everything was pointing to a loss and at
the time it was really frustrating and
also very scary but in the whole
experience it was probably one of the
greatest things that ever happened to me
although I missed out on a lot of things
and I lost a lot of things and we all
did it ended up totally shaping Who I am
as a person luckily she beat cancer she
is totally leukemia free through this
definition with the word loss now that
like no matter what the bad experience
is and no matter what you think you're
going to have to deal with or lose out
on there always will be some unexpected
gain if not greater than the original
loss i had jaw surgery done two years
ago and during the surgery a doctor cut
my nerve in my face and i lost all
feeling in my face for like ever because
of the nerve damage that i have i have
to take a [ __ ] ton of medication every
single day and i keep it in this little
pill box i've learned how to deal with
the feelings of loss by controlling the
way that I view just pain and loss in
general loss of my mom was very
significant especially that time in my
life I was just graduating college she
meant everything to me and it changed me
to become an adult faster changed me the
way I had to approach my life for me
the most recent loss that I've
experienced was somebody who was very
special to me and long before I lost him
in the capacity of death I lost him to a
battle with depression and addiction
where he kind of gave up on himself and
lost himself and I think of lost on a
grander scheme I think that it in a
painful way it brings people back to
themselves and back to their humanity I
lost a lot of friends in 2014
a lot to suicide some to overdoses this
was just such a layering of loss over
loss over loss over loss
constantly reminding me I'm losing these
people especially when it has to do
something like suicide
so I actually moved up to the redwoods
and kind of locked myself away for a
year at this amazing job where I was
working at a wonderful summer camp that
was year round when I was 16 years old
and my grandmother was dying I had the
opportunity to go to the hospital to
visit her but for some reason I can't
crawl into my 16 year old brain I
decided not to I think from that day I
really started to realize that you don't
know what moments you have that are more
fleeting than others had I gone back I
wish I had that that time to not witness
that last moment I decided to change how
I dealt with life and what I felt was
important
[Music]